buenos deseos para el rey del fútbol el
estado de salud de Pelé crea
preocupación en todas partes del planeta
tras la noticia de su hospitalización
exonerantes donamento fue internado en
el hospital israelita Albert Einstein el
pasado martes 29 para una revaluación
del tratamiento de quimioterapia para el
tumor de colon todavía están en
tratamiento y el estado de salud se
mantiene estable futbolistas y
organizaciones del mundo esperan su
mejoría como kilian mbappe rivaldo
Junior la FIFA la conmebol o el equipo
Santos de Brasil en pleno mundial en
doha los fans del Astro no reconocen a
otro como él
significa mucho es el mejor del mundo no
tenemos ningún otro como Pelé
tienen a Maradona en Argentina Brasil
tiene a Ronaldo como el segundo mejor
pero Pelé es el primero el más
importante
Pelé de 82 años es considerado como uno
de los mejores deportistas de todos los
tiempos el periodista Patricio de la
barra en entrevista para 24 analizó su
importancia deportiva y la verdad es que
Pelé Para mí fue uno de los mayores
iconos del fútbol mundial un jugador que
superó todas las marcas se superó marcó
más de mil goles incluso estuvo en
diversas partes del planeta yo no conocí
en Chile incluso cuando deja pequeño y
él ya era un gran Astro en 1958
recordemos que venció ese primer mundial
y de ahí para adelante se tornó para mí
el mejor jugador de o el mejor atleta de
la historia según el periódico fola de
Sao Paulo la quimioterapia del Astro fue
suspendida y ahora está bajo cuidados
palia